6-Mete English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Being in nature has benefits for our physical and mental health.
So wouldn't it be good if instead of giving you a bottle of pills,
your doctor recommended spending time in nature?
That's an interesting idea, Neil. Being outdoors always makes me feel better.
And in Japan, there's even a word for it,
Shinrin Yaku translated into English as forest bathing.
Forest bathing is a type of relaxation that involves being calm and quiet amongst the trees
and using all your senses to observe nature around you while breathing deeply.
It sounds wonderful, Beth.
In this programme, we'll be hearing how one of the world's oldest building materials,
wood, is being used in new ways to build a greener future.
And as usual, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary as well.
Great, but first I have a question for you, Neil.
Britain used to be covered in trees.
In Roman times, it's estimated that as much as 40% of the land was forest.
Trees provided wood, the building material needed for many things,
including buildings, furniture and chips.
So how many trees do you think were needed to build the HMS
victory, Nelson's famous ship at the Battle of Trafalgar in 1805?
Was it A, 4000 trees, B, 5000 trees, or C, 6000 trees?
Well, I have no idea, but I'll guess it was 5000 trees.
Okay, Neil, I'll reveal the correct answer at the end of the programme.
Throughout history, buildings in Britain have been made of timber,
trees that are grown so their wood can be used as a building material.
But in modern times, this has mostly been done by man-made materials,
brick, concrete and steel.
One of those arguing for a return to wood is architects Michael Rammage,
talking here to BBC Radio 4 programme Rare Earth.
There is some compelling evidence to show that children in schools made of wood
learn better, they have greater concentration, lower stress, lower heartbeats,
and there's compelling evidence to show that patients in hospitals recover better in both rooms
made of wood or other natural materials, and also in rooms that have views of nature out the window.
Michael believes there is compelling evidence for the health benefits of wood.
If something is compelling, it's so convincing that you believe it.
As evidence, he gives examples that wooden schools help children learn.
But there's another compelling reason to build with wood. The carbon which wood captures helps
combat climate change. It's why many governments around the world want to replace the carbon
intensive production of concrete and steel with biobased materials like wood.
Here's architect Michael Rammage again describing the possibilities of wooden buildings to
BBC Radio 4's Rare Earth.
We look at the possibilities of building with wood and other materials we can grow, bamboo,
hemp, flax, and how we can use them intelligently as replacements for steel and concrete in the world
that we create around us. We've looked at skyscrapers, we've looked at housing, we've looked at
schools and there are a whole range of buildings that we can build if we use wood well.
Michael builds with natural materials which can be sustainably grown, including bamboo and hemp,
a family of plants which are used to make many products such as rope and cloth.
He thinks these natural biobased materials will work if they are used intelligently
in a clever, intelligent way.
A good example of this is plywood, the first new material in construction since the invention of
reinforced concrete a hundred years ago. Tests prove that plywood made from layers of pine,
which are laid crossways and then glued together, is as strong as steel.
It's already been used to build skyscrapers, the very tall modern buildings you often see in cities.
An 85 metre high skyscraper in Norway and an even taller one at 87 metres the world's tallest
in Milwaukee, USA. Strong, relaxing, and eco-friendly. It seems that building with wood is good for
the future as well as the past, which reminds me of my question, Neil. Yes, you asked me how many
trees we used as timber for Nelson's famous warship HMS Victory and I guessed it was 5,000.
Which was close, but the wrong answer I'm afraid. It was even more, around 6,000 trees,
most of which were oak, with some timbers over half a metre thick.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learnt in this programme starting with forest bathing,
being in nature and immersing your senses in the experience for its physical and mental health
benefits. Timber is trees grown so the wood can be used for building. If an argument or evidence is
compelling, it's strong, convincing, and believable. The adverb intelligently means done in a way
showing intelligence and skill. Hemp is a family of plants, some of which are used to make a
rope and strong cloth. And finally, a skyscraper is a very tall modern building, usually in a city.
Once again, our six minutes are up, but remember to join us again next time for more
trending topics and useful vocabulary here at 6 Minute English. Goodbye for now. Bye!